Let's get back to our compiler.
Again, in matchset I pulled out one more clause.
This is a clause for sequence, and this is what we return.
If I want to write the compiler for that sequence clause,
I would say let's define seq(x, y).
It's a compiler so it's going to return a function that operates on x and y,
take as input a text and then returns as result.
We could take exactly that result.
While I'm moving everything to this more functional notation,
I decided let's just show you a different way to do this.
This way to do it would be fine, but I could have the function return that.
But instead, let's have it say what we're really trying to do is form a union of sets.
What are the sets? The sets that we're going to apply union to.
First we apply x to the text, and that's going to give us a set of remainders.
For each of the remainders, we want to apply y to it.
What we're saying is we're going to map y to each set of remainders.
Then we want to union all those together.
Now, union, it turns out, doesn't take a collection.
It takes arguments with union a, b, c.
So we want to turn this collection into a list of arguments to union.
We do that using this apply notation of saying let's just put a star in there.
Now, we've got out compiler for sequence.
It's the function from text to the set that results from finding all the remainders for x
and then finding all the remainders from each of those after we apply y.
Unioning all those together in union will eliminate duplicates.
Now it's your turn to do one.
This was the definition of alt in the interpreter matchset.
Now I want you to write the definition of the compiler for alt,
take a pattern for (x, y), and return the function that implements that.